bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est avec
michael michael qui a une entreprise
labellisée franchir ricky un produit qui
est vraiment dire que s'adresse à tous
les sportifs
soit tu peux nous présenter
oui bien sûr bonjour à tous en tout donc
on essaye par che parts ont fait les
brassards de sports innovants et
connecté en fait le point c'est que tout
le monde
pour tous le même problème c'est qu'on
sait pas trop quoi faire de nos
téléphones et pas tomber dans le
brassard mais ils restent bloquées en
ville grâce à un instant le bras c'est
la galère en fait on a créé un
on a créé deux textos la première caisse
affiche de l'augmenter ce qui permet
tout simplement la cda son téléphone
très facilement en fait on mais on me
téléphone dans une
pochette magnétique qui permet de
projets de téléphone contre la pluie par
exemple est tout simplement lui remette
sur le bras tulard clip directement ça m
embête alors qu'avant je suis hyper
c'est costaud ça a été fait et testé en
reining en vélo en équitation vtt
vraiment
des grosses rester non productives du
jeu face à ces hypers et a pas de soucis
web et tu me disais un truc qui te faire
l'intéressant terre que les aimants sont
deux côtés si oui parce qu'on voit bien
la voilà les juments sont là et pas du
tout du côté du smartphone ce qui fait
que même si le smartphone est protégé on
a pas de risque au niveau du gps des
choses comme ça exactement il ya pas de
chant peinture magnétique intérieur et
puis évidemment la pochette est
complètement tactile on à l'empreinte
digitale on utilise ces applis qu'on ne
les utilisent normalement et extraits de
renvoi c'est génial ça c'est la première
techno première techno hockey et la
seconde pour les sportifs ou chevronnés
sur ne reçoivent de petits objectifs
on a intégré un capteur de fréquence
cardiaque courrier ici qui serait dans
la petite coque silicone et annoncé
qu'elle a et qui va mesurer la fréquence
qu'avec au niveau du bras et l'envoyer
en bleu tous sur le téléphone avec
l'implication connaissait
exactement on se connecte ce qui est
important c'est mentionné toutes les
applis existence travail crises
africaines demande aux autres comme ça
on n'a pas besoin de changer d'habits de
télécharger la nôtre nous les data entre
eux occupent là d'accord n'avait pas des
marchands donné hier tu me disais que il
faut être bras nus pour que ça marche
ouais donc ça veut dire que tu coures
antichoc way ou torse news
barak d'accord et sinon tu avais une
autre solution
ouais et donc forcément quand on hiver
on seront
l'acadien ses intuitions qui pourrit on
a un petit un petit kit dans l'hiver
donc on est on est tout simplement le
capteur est ici en maison kit complet
autour du bras on met ces manchons de
pardessus et après c'est pas en avant et
donc du coup ça permet de courir avec en
fond une petite simplement l'utiliser
sur d'autres sports comme la boxe ou le
vélo ou voilà son vélo avec le téléphone
de son bidon et on assume petit castor
de haut niveau du bras lorsque tu me
disais parce qu'on se rend pas trop
compte comme ça mais c'est quoi le truc
qui te pique quand une fois que tu leur
poser là ça bouge pas du tout pas hyper
léger le capteur il parlait alors là
c'est seulement en vidéo brandit pas
compte mais quand on tient comme ça
c'est s'appelle rien quoi ça baisse
vraiment rien génial et est ce qui est
intéressant c'est que comme si ça bouge
pas sur le bras et l'intérêt commun
c'est qu'ils aient moins de mouvements
qui est mis en lumière ces convois une
bien meilleure précision sémantique là
tous nos premiers clients
on n'a pas eu notre comparatif avec des
ceintures cardio qui reste est la
référence en termes de précision
on a la même question d'une ceinture
cardio pour un confort qui est bien
supérieur
d'accord cool alors du coup vous avez
utilisé deux types de produits oui
exactement
on a
la version 10 6 qui est la version non
connectés avec la fonction magnétique le
brassard donc sur magnetic n'est pas
connectée donc pas le frère du hockey et
on va la version celle ci qui est
magnétique plus le capteur cardio et le
petit kit pour l'hiver qui est fourni
avec génial génial
alors ces produits on peut y retrouver
ou alors c'est produire la preuve
évidemment sur internet certains sites
sur amazon sur des sites comme la fnac
ldlc je mets le lien de leur site sur
internet
j'allais voir et on les retrouve en
magasins et magasins big on est
aujourd'hui ici présent les magasins
fnac
chez les magasins le pape au running
puis quelques de six magasins
indépendants à travers la france génial
super et du coup vous serez présent
aussi aux crs à las vegas pour présenter
pour présenter le du business pour
présenter puis pour montrer ce qu'on a
réussi à faire en mai dernier on était à
l'étape de croco génial tout est livré
tout en maintenant vous avez sorti de
prendre les deux produits en un an
et puis on annoncera un petit petite
surprise aussi un nouveau produit
exactement nouveau produit qui va
arriver au congrès sur l'or qui arrivera
pour septembre et sur l'univers du vélo
cool bombers note de voir ça dure ça
roule bon bah écoute
merci à toi merci je vous invite à aller
découvrir ce produit
si vous êtes fan de sport parce que
c'est vraiment une part pratique est
super bien et surtout c'est made in
france and take ça se voit ici je vous
invite à laisser les commentaires pour
dire si vous faites du sport ce que vous
utilisiez comme solution est ce que
celle ci pourrait vous intéresser
mettez des jolies choses que vous
abonner parce qu'on a toujours plus de
contenu pour parler de high tech et de
high tech 116
merci a bientot soyez sages et portez
vous bien tiens